der ist auch immer in meinen runden ich
weiß nicht wie es macht aber das immer
immer immer immer in mein rund servus s
kids und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge minecraft wir spielen heute
tsg auf geo mm
die dot net und aber noch keiner bis
dahin dankeschön schon in den weg dass
sogar den weg standen
sr leute deutschland wird weiterhin von
einer katastrophalen hitzewelle
heimgesucht
so auch ich deswegen mal aufzug hier
bisschen sommerlich luftig leicht noch
sommerlich luftige leichter als beim
letzten mal
hier kann ich kiste gestik ist der woche
seine gäste ja ich habe bock hier auf 64
erst in den letzten tagen
ich spiele eigentlich nur noch 64 sg und
was ganz witzig ist ich komme irgendwie
ein 64er es geht besser zurecht als in
24 er warum auch immer
auch wenn die runden jetzt hier und ich
weiß gar nicht ist der spielmodus fällt
nicht mehr so beliebt ich habe das
gefühl dass hier und nur noch ganz ganz
selten voll werden obwohl heute
eigentlich eine super voraussetzungen
ist heute samstag
okay leute sind vielleicht im freibad
aber ansonsten haben die alle zeit denke
ich mal mittags dann auch alle
ausgeschlafen eigentlich sollten die
server rappelvoll sein
ich weiß nie es 460 es geht vielleicht
am besten ist es besser auf sein besteht
vielleicht out wie jemand der vor die
tür gegangen ist kann es sein ohne eis
kleine lecks da freut man sich mal
wieder alex findet so jetzt gucken wir
mal wusste erste gegner der im haus da
hinten kommt aber noch einer
finde ich nicht so geil ich würde mich
gerade eben schon richtig häufig
abgestaubt dadurch wir wissen hast
geschoben
vielleicht darf ich jetzt mal dran an
die freude machen ein bisschen abstauben
kommt mir diese ehre zuteil wurde
pro jahr junge junge das equipment der
hatte equipment und wie
oh ja da schaut man doch gerne projekte
protection egal
wir ziehen den change and heran sehr
neiße sache alter und all das wäre
richtig
so werde mich auf den job schon auf wie
damit ich keine libysche zu machen muss
es regeln und so ich habe keine
möglichkeit jetzt das zeug gegen die
kaputt zu machen
dann lasse ich es einfach mal liegen
auch wenn ich das nicht so gerne mache
ich brauche jetzt alles nicht ja wir
sind endlich schon heavy erprobt und da
sind zwei oder doch mal rein sagt dilek
sich lieber nicht mit uns an nun wieder
im boden backt ja ach komm schon das ist
so lächerlich was man dagegen machen
danke bank noch mehr an boden
der bau nicht mehr viele leben er hat
nicht mehr viele leben
der kollege hat nicht mal wieder leben
aber man trifft inhalt kaum weil er so
ein bisschen im boden baghdatis gefühl
wir müssen das überlegen irgendwie muss
man den kriegen vielleicht irgendwo
langen locken
ich weiß nicht ich weiß es nicht ich
habe das dumpfe gefühl dass er doch noch
ein bisschen mehr leben hat da ist ein
anderer
natürlich haben da sieht man so schön
die rüstung der kommt auch auf jeden
fall eines brandes stehen bleiben das
war eine schlechte idee
jetzt stehen zu bleiben deswegen laufen
erst mal weiter vielleicht macht er
irgendwelche fehler da würde ich sagen
wir spekulieren
hier weiter
afag deshalb direkt hinter uns aber der
kann auch nicht viele leben haben wir es
ehrlich der kann nicht so viele leben
haben jetzt sagt das war es jetzt um uns
zu machen
du bist du bist du bist du bist sehr
schön und der andere kommt jetzt bitte
nicht hinterher
denn ich darf nur abstauben mich
abstauben hier nicht erlaubt dass es das
ist unidirektionalen abstauben hier
nicht obwohl julia seiner holla die
waldfee so ich habe ich schon gesehen
du warst bist schon auf meinem kommt
passiert zwei pfeile sehr schön und
jetzt hinterher
ja ja ja leg dich nicht mit escape schön
drei weitere pfeile jetzt ort kein spam
wir sollten nicht so dumm wie ins wasser
hinterher sprang regal nehme ich hier
mit so was ist mir noch ein feuerzeug
ich will schon aus dem wasser raus ganz
schnell
ich mag ist überhaupt nicht im wasser zu
sein da wird man immer so heftig heftig
heftig weg gebaut wird so wie es gerade
bei dem anderen gemacht habe geht es mir
nämlich auch selbst oft und das finde
ich eigentlich nicht so nice folter 43
schon mal ganz gut da hatte ich vor
immer die alle leute aber da ich jetzt
zwecks vario training nicht mehr mit
anderen spiele hab ich einfach mein
fahrzeug auf 43 da komme ich mich besser
hin weil er vier ist oder clique ich
mich oftmals klicke mich dann auf die
drei und wenn ich auf der 4 heiltränke
haben auf der drei feuer dann ziemlich
unterrichtet druck will vier drücken
druck aber drei sind mich selbst an und
stellt den dümmsten todes gibt und dann
muss wieder ausrasten
das wollen wir auch nicht deswegen muss
jetzt alles klar und wir kommen
scheinbar gleich schon ins deathmatch
nice das finde ich gut
gucken wir mal bitte nicht die kleine
arena die kleine ist nämlich ein
bisschen random und das ist die große
sehr schön auf der kamera mich ein
bisschen spielen freier tier ist auch
immer in meinen runden ich weiß nicht
wie es macht aber das immer immer immer
immer in meinen runden die in der mitte
gibt glaube ich kein schwertner
wisst ihr was dann hole ich mir den
medien hier
der hier wollte gerade ein bisschen bei
den anderen beiden abstauben dafür muss
ich jetzt unbedingt bestrafen
denn ich bin hier die absolute und
instanz wenn sie uns abstauben den
bestraften abstauben geht so deswegen
muss jetzt drauf gehen sagt widmann mit
a-ha ok erstaunt hat er noch halt tage
gehabt level level level nein es reicht
nicht für level und sieht aus als würde
ich jetzt gegen den typen spielen der
ungefähr jedes einzelne mal meine runden
ist also wirklich ich habe fast das
gefühl hat mir nach oder spiel den
ganzen tag nur 64 ist es kann auch sein
auf jeden fall jetzt and fight gegen ihn
das mich kurz reagan noch ganz nett wenn
ihr jeden fall die firma tritt ja was
macht ihr hier und jetzt durch die durch
den durch die durch die durch die durch
die durch das geld auch prozent ich
dauernd ja sehr schön
kpmg
bitte achte auf deine wortwahl okay ggf
sie danke das war's von heute vom hitze
update bei mir ist es wieder so dass
eventuell hatte mir mein leben rettet
ich hoffe ihr kommt auch irgendwie klar
da draußen ansonsten hoffe ich dass das
video ein bisschen abgelenkt von der
hitze das gerne daumen nach oben da
möchte gefallen hat wir sehen uns wieder
haut rein macht's gut und